e
e e
I just like open up with the really the
the first question
and we really appreciate your cander and
your your uh answering tough questions
over the last couple of months as we go
through this and again our our
perspective is one recognizing that we
we need to have landfills but two that
those landfills need to be um safe for
the environment and safe for the public
and and you guys I know are caught right
in the middle of trying to make rules
that balance those two things
um what we've heard and and you know
we're talking about this morning is um
there's been a lot of discussion about
numbers and and flow and 10 to minus 3
versus 10 to Minus 5 and all that my my
biggest question guys
is as you sit there and you rewrite the
rules our desire all along up front is
to make sure that when that next land
landfill comes whenever it
comes that when it goes in it is safer
for the environment and safer for the
public than what currently
exists and that's the question and so
how are these rules that you're creating
today making it safer
over great well thank you uh Mr chair
and members of the committee for the
record my name is Mike willat I serve as
director of the waste management
division for New Hampshire Dees and I'm
joined this morning by leam McKenna who
serves as administrator of our Solid
Waste Management Bureau um we're happy
to be before you this morning to present
this letter in response to your question
um about how um our proposed Solid Waste
rules will um provide uh additional
protections um and and improve uh
protection protectiveness of human
health and safety as well as protection
of the environment um your letter in
your question had asked you maybe you
know five or seven uh examples and as we
look through the rules and analyze that
we realized that that that there are a
lot more than that and rather than just
highlight them we we thought we'd uh
we'd actually outline in the letter all
the ones that we that really came to
mind as being adding significant
protections um there are probably more
but but these I think are ones that
stood out to us um what I'd like to do
this morning is really just highlight uh
about seven of them that I think you
know maybe could could come to the top
of the list um I also before we finish I
would like to turn it over to um uh Leah
to to give you some idea where we're at
with the ru making because that Ru
making notice will be filed shortly and
I want to just talk to you about we'd
like to just talk to you about the
logistics of that so um I I think it's
important before I discuss these
individual um improvements to understand
as we've discussed previously that
um all of our rules really work together
a rule set works together to provide
protections and you can't just look at
one rule and say well that either does
or doesn't provide a protection you have
to look at it in the context of how it
works with other other rules in the uh
in the set and of course our rules as
you know you you folks probably
understand these rules better than a lot
of people do um they they're expansive
and they cover a lot of ground so it's
important to look at them as a holistic
set rather than one individual provision
ision
so to highlight a few of those
provisions and and in your letter I
think you'll note that the the the um
citations are they're not prioritized by
by level of protection they're actually
prior they're actually ordered in terms
of um in the nomenclature of the rules
where they occur in the rules so that
way if you were looking at a set of
rules and you wanted to go through the
letter you wouldn't have to keep
flipping Pages back and forth you could
keep going forward and you could read
you know look at those individual rules
so the first one that I'd like to
highlight is uh en envs sw80 and and for
purposes of of discussion here I'm going
to all of these rules have the the
prefix en vsw I'm going to avoid that so
you don't hear me you know giving you an
alphabet soup this morning so I'm just
going to talk about the the the
numerical citation of the rule so um to
start off nvsw
842b 80403 B
and
80405 B are proposed for revision to add
consideration of storm water lee8 and
landfill gas infrastructure location
during landfill sighting uh the current
rules only require the landfill
footprint be considered in these site
specific sighting requirements the
proposed change will improve protection
of groundwater surface waters and other
potential
receptors uh the second one that I'd
like to highlight is 80403 C
and that is uh proposed for addition to
require that a landfill and Associated
storm water lee8 and landfill gas
infrastructure be cited such that a
discharge spill leachate release or
other failure of the waste containment
system or Associated infrastructure will
be detected and assessed and Remediation
initiated prior to contamination
reaching any perennial water body um
while a parallel requirement exists in
the groundwater protection requirements
in the rules um no such provision
currently exists to protect surface
waters so this proposed change will um
clearly improve protection of surface
waters when compared to the previous
rule um The Third One 80403 D is
proposed for revision to increase the
distance between a landfill footprint
and a perennial surface water body from
200 to 500 ft with the exception of
first and second order perennial streams
for which distances proposed to remain
at 200 ft now current the landfill
footprint is required to be 200 ft from
all perennial surface water bodies under
the existing rules the proposed change
increases the distance between the
landfill footprint and surface waters
thus increasing the time a Pere has to
address and remediate potential Rees
releases from the landfill and we note
that um the site specific sighting
requirements and the minimum setback
distance requirements work in tandem to
enhance protection of groundwater
surface waters and other potential
receptors so that it's important to
understand there are other Provisions
that that also influence the
interpretation of that um the fourth one
EnV SW
859b and G are proposed for revision to
increase the designed capacity of storm
Water Management Systems from that
required for a 25e 24-hour storm event
to that required for a 50-year storm
event excuse me current rules require
storm water systems be designed to
accommodate just the 25-year storm event
this proposed change will better address
the increases and frequency and duration
of storm events due to climate change
and provide uh protections with respect
to uh both generation of lee8 and
management of storm water on the on the
landfill
site uh that is the citation for that is
8059 B and G that's going to be number
12 in the letter sure oh sorry about
that yeah so we went 1 3 4 12 so
far and then if you can maybe find that
one 80512 a 15 so number 13 in the
letter um s nvsw
852a is proposed for
revision to require a composite liner
the current rule only requires a geome
membrane liner and this is for MSW
landfills that already require a double
liner in the current rules they
essentially require that both of those
be or that at least one is a geomembrane
liner the new revision will require that
one of those liners be a composite liner
which to understand the definition of
that would either be a GC what's known
as a GCL liner so a geosynthetic
composite liner which is actually a
geomembrane liner a plastic liner that
is bonded to um a a clay material that
uh helps to provide additional
protection from leakage even in the
event of a small puncture um and then um
or a composite liner can be a
geomembrane plastic liner coupled with a
layer of of engineered soil so this will
provide uh improve the effectiveness and
the protectiveness of liner systems um
and again assist in self-healing any
pinhole leaks that could
occur the sixth one um 806 8
G3 which is number 16 in the letter uh
is proposed to be added to require
landfill permites to perform an annual
Odor Control evaluation report current
rules don't require comprehensive
evaluations of odor issues and this
proposed change will assist in reducing
nuisance odor conditions and you know
there are a number of things in here
that are related to what are termed
nuisance things like litter and odor and
noise but we understand that that those
are quality of life issues that can have
an indirect effect on on on health so we
think they're meaningful and important
changes um and then the uh the last one
I'd like to highlight is EnV SW 8068 D6
which is number 17 and that uh is
proposed to add requirements for um per
P per and poly floral alcohol what I
think everybody now knows as pasas um
testing of leech Aid and um current
rules don't specifically require lee8 to
be tested for pasas although we have
asked in in our in our in our our
landfill operators have done initial at
least one round of initial testing of
their lee8 for pasas but this proposed
change will ensure that Peres are
collecting data on the concentrations of
pasas in lee8 and preparing for future
regulations that will likely limit or
change the way that pasas in the way
that lee8 containing pasas can be
treated are disposed of in the future so
that's just highlighting a few of the of
the 19 that are outlined in the letter
um and with that I I just want to uh
turn it over to Leah for just a moment
to talk about the status of this
proposed rul making sure good morning
for the record Leah McKenna
administrator of the solid waste
management
Bureau so where we are at is a rul
making notice was filed to the office of
legislative Services last Thursday which
means fingers crossed it will be
published in the rul making register
this Thursday and in that uh will be
links to the initial proposal so the the
um the version of the rules that you've
all seen as well as the date and time
and location for the public hearing
which if all things are AO that would be
scheduled for the 20th of May at the DMV
Auditorium I believe it will start at 1M
but the hearing notice will will uh will
note all of that
yeah just for the record do you plan on
that being a hybrid format or is it
iners only format great question sorry
about that yes it's it'll be hybrid uh
so I believe the DMV Auditorium holds
100 and we anticipate there'll be uh
plenty of folks that will attend um
hybrid and there will be there should be
enough time to have everyone um deliver
their um their comments and then we'll
we will explain in great detail I think
repetitively um how uh to ensure that
folks submit um comments to us in
writing and we will note what the length
of the public comment period will be the
formal public comment period um and then
we go we go through um make adjustments
to the rules as we see fit based on the
feedback that we receive uh and then we
would file the initial proposal uh at
some point um soon after that and then
and then the jail car jail car process
starts and and like the director
mentioned a couple of um meetings ago we
will because of the schedule we will not
meet the July 1st uh expiration date but
that's totally okay um because we've
already filed the rul making notice we
get we get an extension that's going to
go far beyond what we will need in order
to get these rules
reopt and and if I could before we go to
questions just I want to I want to thank
you I want to reiterate that um uh the
subcommittee's input in this has been
very important to this process we've
been engaged in really I think a I guess
you could call a pre preformal
rulemaking uh process that really I
think is um I'm not sure it's been
duplicated in for any other the
rulemakings that we've done in the
division um the subcommittee's input has
been very important to us it's it has
informed this this rule set that we've
just described to you and uh we look
forward to moving forward in the
rulemaking process and to hearing from
uh either the subcommittee as a unit or
or the individual members um in the in
the in the public comment and uh and
hearing period that we will have
I appreciate that I just one second um
on the last two that you talked about
Parra 16 and 17 both of those required
uh testing on an annual basis one for PS
and one for odor so in the rules how
does that work if so example you know if
there's an odor that is bad I mean who
determines that and then what's the
remediation process is that in the rules
or or is that how's that determined sure
so so actually that the the rule that I
highlighted is is basically saying that
there needs to be a um an annual odor
evaluation and what that really amounts
to it's not testing at the site what
that really is is looking at the way
that we learn about odor and the way we
deal with odor at landfills is people
report it they experience odor problems
they and and what we have done for years
is um in the first instance we we want
the problem to be resolved in some cases
you know certainly landfills gas is is
odorous there's no question about it and
it's really about management of that gas
and those emissions that that is whether
or not you're successful in controlling
odors in a way that your neighbors to
the facility don't have a bad experience
and um in some cases when there's odor
it could be they you know to be candid
you know wastewater treatment sludge is
often disposed of at landfills and that
can generate odor complaints if it's not
done really well and and effectively um
it can create off-site odor complaints
so um what we encourage people to do as
soon as they experiencing oders to call
the landfill directly and let them know
that because landfill doesn't always
know the landfill operators don't always
know that that's happening and that
sometimes in real time they can take
make changes that will improve that um
there are a lot of changes have been
made to the procedures for off the time
and the manner and and the type of uh
sludge that they or the way that the
sludge is treated um we a while back
required that that um um landfill or
that wastewater treatment sledges be uh
pre-treated for odor prior to arriving
at the landfill let us the lime
stabilization process that helps control
odors so there's that um but also we we
we get complaints and we encourage
people to let us know when they're
experiencing odor complaints so those
get compiled over time and um but what
this rule change will mean is that
there's a standing requirement to do an
evaluation of how things have gone over
the last year with respect to odors and
and as part of that there are Provisions
in the rule that set out exactly what
that evaluation should entail and and a
requirement that if there are problems
that are not being addressed well that
there be a plan to address odors um
we've had uh over at a number of our
facilities over the years we've had some
sort of persistent odor problems that
have required us to kind of even from an
enforcement standpoint require someone
to a landfill operator to um you know
bring in a consultant to really work on
why their odor problems are happening um
in some cases it's uh you know a
maintenance problem or or a breakdown
problem with landfill gas management and
if people are paying close attention to
that um they can ensure that they
identify it and then make whatever
repairs are necessary to control those
odors so there's a lot that goes into it
okay uh all right I got to follow up but
let me get to representative
Jana thank you Mr chair uh thank you
both for being here and for for taking
my question so I appreciate the the
statement the comments you made a minute
ago about working with the subcommittee
during this process uh but what I'm
hoping for is that you could kind of put
some tangible meat on those bones
because I'm having a hard time seeing
that frankly I can point to several
cases where industry feedback has been
directly Incorporated ated into the
changes I can point to those I can see
those I have a really hard time seeing
at this point how feedback provided by
this subcommittee the subcommittee has
been Incorporated so if you could help
me by pointing to some specifics where
you have
heard uh feedback from the subcommittee
that has shaped the drafting of the the
rules so I I think I got this question
last time and I in the way I responded
and I'll respond again is that I I I I
don't know that I can necessarily right
now point to a specific thing that was
changed because of something on this
that this committee said um as we always
do when we're rul making we're taking
input from a variety a diverse group of
stakeholders people who have a different
sort of dog in the fight with regard to
our rules and um as we hear input from
those various parties it's incumbent on
us to decide what makes sense to us
what's real what who's got a point or
who is just you know maybe raising
something that that we we can't address
or that that it's we're not able to to
deal with and so we make a lot of
individual decisions about where a rule
is going to be what it specifically is
going to say what what standards it's
going to set and we're influenced by
everything that we hear from all of
those diverse stakeholders and so that's
really what I was referring to when I
said this subcommittee has um influenced
these rules and improved them because
we're hearing from a group of very
interested and educated stakeholders who
have really put this committee must be
commended for the effort and the time it
has put into reviewing these rules and
understanding them and asking questions
about them and as we uh you know we we
heard you're right we heard input from
the industry and we did make some
changes based on that that input um but
in many cases and in most cases we
didn't make the exact change that they
would like we we we did something
different we may have you know uh eased
a particular standard because it we we
learned after career review that it
probably couldn't be complied with or it
would create unintended consequences but
in most cases um because we're hearing
from a diverse group of stakeholders um
we land somewhere in the middle if you
will and um I think that's really what I
was referring to when and you have to
look at that in a very holistic sense
ask follow one second let me go here and
then go
ahead thank you Mr chair for taking my
question and thank you for taking my
question as well um so I have a couple
of things that I'm still chewing on
thinking about perhaps uh maybe offering
some additional comments at a later time
so if it's okay may I ask some of these
clarifying questions or of course okay
um so under 8069 which is what noted
here as well under other operating
standards
um there had been some strikethroughs
enumerating corrective action plans for
reports um that were in I think
FNG uh of the draft that was on eight
uh uh 03824 that we
received and so my question to you all
was just sort of it looks like now um it
it's requiring the permit uh shall post
on the facility website a contact us
form but it
looks like in the previous iterations
there had been actually sort of a notice
to the public of types of complaints
that were lodged or am I misinterpreting
that I'm I'm sorry could you I'm not
sure I understand your question I
apologize so the question I'm asking is
so that that the strikethroughs that I
see seem to be taking out what I'm maybe
I'm misinterpreting it to be is that uh
responses to courses of action through
through other types of complaints it
says the invest uh this is regarding um
identifying potential causes of
appropriate response and actions which
shall be reported to the department in
writing in the form of a proposed action
plan and that has been stricken through
as well as subsection G saying the
permit permit shall Implement approved
response action plans and I was
interpreting because there is a a new
addition in there with a website contact
us kind
I'm confused is that simply a receptacle
to receive complaints and then they then
forward them on to you or what the CH
what is the change there I'm looking to
see if we just moved that section to the
reporting section so just a give me a
give me a moment okay sorry about that
yeah I'm I'm going to guess that's what
it is because if anything we were trying
to make sure that we improved upon and
and had a clearer and and more effective
means of dealing with with complaints so
um that is one of the frustrating things
about the rules you see a strike through
and you think wow why is that being
removed and then in many cases it's
simply being relocated with do you want
to do you want to try to find that and
then did you have one other one I did
have uh one other one okay um and with
regard to section
80404 and that was um setbacks I think a
th000 foot setbacks for high congregate
settings that were named um such as
schools
Etc is that 80404 D yes that's number
six on your
response yes and so my question was is
the list that is um noted in your rules
draft exhaustive and meant to be
prescriptive because there's other high
congregate settings that I could think
of like nursing homes or jails or things
like that that are not
listed actually in 80404 C um
Residential Care Facilities nursing
homes and prisons are addressed okay
sorry apologize thank you and
representative hton
yes thank you very much and good morning
morning I'm interested in the topic of
sludge it's absolutely new to did you
wake up at 4:00 in the morning think
about sludge no actually I read an
article in one of the environmental mags
that I get and they were talking about
sludge being used as fertilizer yes
ma'am do we still do that there there is
a program for um land application of
what are termed biosolids but it's a
certain Cate of wastewater treatment
sludges um and that has been implemented
in New Hampshire for for several decades
um and um it's being certainly subjected
to additional scrutiny right now and has
been for the last several years because
of p and if you follow the news uh in
our neighboring state of Maine they've
had tremendous problems with it um and
and the reason that it's not to say that
we don't see p in New Hampshire sludge
and that it hasn't created ated problems
here um but we've experienced not the
same level of impact that Maine has and
the source the the primary source of
pasas in sludge is actually um in uh or
high high concentrations of P fassen
sludge is not necessarily from Municipal
Wastewater sludge but from um paper mill
sludge and or Municipal Wastewater
plants that receive wastewaters from
paper mills and of course Main has a a
long history of of of paper making and a
lot of towns um and cities in Maine have
have or have had you know significant
paper mills in their in their location
and um because past was used in the
paper making process um in particular
there was a mill in Maine that that used
um P to make Chinet you you're probably
familiar with that and it's a reason
that it works so good at the picnic and
um that those sledges were very high and
unfortunately there are a number of
farms in Maine that received significant
amounts of land application of those
sledges um which resulted in very high
past concentration some cases you know
destroying a dairy herd um or creating
you know basically a you know
bankrupting a farmer because their their
fields are no longer and as far as
you're aware may I ume we don't do that
well we there is some history of short
paper fiber sludge used that's what they
they call it SPF short paper fiber it's
it's basically paper mill sludge in New
Hampshire um it was actually pretty
popular to use it um for interestingly
enough for closure of online landfills
so the the the benefits of using any of
these sludges is that they provide
organic material and nutrients for
develop of a vegetate development of a
vegetative cover over landfill so you
may know we have you know almost 300
online landfills in the state that were
operated by mostly by
municipalities they had a long Legacy of
contamination of groundwater um and
drinking water and they they just didn't
you know we know we know that an unline
landfill was not a good way to manage
waste so back in the 80s we started
closing those facilities directing the
municipalities to close them we even had
a grant program to help offset the cost
of doing that and it was determined that
the most effective way to do that
closure was to provide a low
permeability cap a cap that would when
necessarily a plastic cap in some cases
but a low permeability soil that would
limit the amount of infiltration of
water to the uh to the landfill and um
when you do that you want to get it
vegetated and as it turned out use of
short paper fiber sludge was a common
way to provide uh adequate uh organic
material and and nutrients to get a
vegetative cover going on there so we do
have some landfills that and it's hard
to discern because we know that the
waste at those landfills received even
just from Municipal Solid Waste contain
pasas um but but we do see that the the
facilities that were closed with this
short paper fiber sludge tend to have
higher levels of past contamination in
the groundwater than the facilities that
were not so we have had a problem with
it we we and and I know Anthony drwan
who I think has spoken maybe to this
group before or to to the full committee
um has is our um land application um
coordinator at Dees really knowledgeable
about this has done a tremendous amount
of work and that program continues to
morph and change the the the goal is to
make sure that any Wastewater sludges
that are land applied don't have high
concentrations of P we did a lot of work
over the last couple years to develop
soil standards and and the work of for
for past cleanup and as part of that we
also looked at what you know might be a
safe level of past to have in sludges
where they could still be land applied
but would not impose would not threaten
groundwater quality and so that work is
still ongoing to set those standards
thank you I think I just wanted to put a
pin in that topic sure and so just a a
follow a followup if you can just hold
on one second so does the rules that
you're going through now that we're
discussing apply to the sludge
issue it they apply to the Sledge issue
only to the extent that many wastewater
treatment sledges are disposed of in
landfill s the the the regulatory status
of of of wastewater treatment sludges is
a little unique they are um regulated
actually separately from solid wastes
they are not a solid waste unless they
are disposed of in a permited solid
waste facility so when sludge comes
through the gate at a landfill it
becomes a solid waste and it's being and
it's its disposal is regulated like any
other Solid Waste at that facility but
um it's it's regula under separate law
when it's not disposed of a solid waste
facility under our Water Division okay
thank you representative potenzo just a
follow-up question about that so is are
you telling me that all sludge is tested
before it is applied like for a farm
before it's applied for if it's put on
top of a landfill I just want to be
clear all the sludge is tested for the
past concentrations in it before it is
going out to these farms and or anybody
that's using it in an agricultural sense
cuz that's the problem earily that's
going on in Maine is they were not okay
so there are reg rigorous testing
requirements for sludge I I can't I'm
not an expert on specifically what the
frequency is but certainly that's
something that our our folks in the land
application program could could or the
biosolids program could could answer
that more specifically but yes there are
I know there are rigorous testing
requirements and Dees does some of its
own testing to assist those uh
facilities with developing standards and
or developing
uh options for for managing their
sludge and Miss McKennon did you sure
you found thank you for waking up
thinking about sludge it gave me the
opportunity to find to find the rule
that the uh so it it's it indeed still
exists okay it was just moved to
8068 starting at letter
L so I just moved one section above okay
thank you cool thank you and and
representative Jam you had a followup
yes thank you Mr chair uh and if so my
question this is something we have
spoken about specifically before and it
was the language um I was searching for
the most recent version of the rules so
maybe my citation isn't going to be
right in the in
previous iteration it was at 80402 C and
it has to do with the average uh
hydraulic conductivity uh and the one of
the questions one of the discussions we
had is the difference between average
and
representative uh and in a conversation
we had I said
um average is not necessarily
representative right and so raised the
possibility that you could drill uh you
Wells or test Wells right you could test
within a very confined area to
manipulate an average to produce a
predetermined result and and you're
you're had said something to the effect
of if you got an application and you saw
that something like that was happening
that an applicant was trying to
manipulate the process that way right if
you had 10 drills in a very uh small uh
area that that's something that you
would flag and so the question I asked
you at that time and and I'll ask it
again is can you point to a specific
place in
rules uh that gives you the the power to
do that right so if if you're going to
say to if you're going to try to call
somebody out and say no this is not an
acceptable s Le right where in rules
does it
specify how such a determination is to
be
made I'm not sure that the rules are
that um detailed or spec or explicit
about that I can tell you that when we
you know there is a requirement to do a
hydro geological study which includes
evaluation of soil conditions um when
when citing a new landfill or when uh
proposing to expand an existing ing
landfill and that study is subject
subjected to review by our licensed
hydrogeologists and engineers at the
agency and um if we feel that I think
maybe to answer your question it may be
that um it's it's a little oblique but I
think it gets us there um and this has
happened with other things where we just
feel we don't have enough information to
make a determination that something
meets a rule or is compliant and that is
a basis for denial if we believe that we
don't have enough information to
determine that a rule has been complied
with or that a standard has been met we
can deny the permit application that now
that may be a little nuclear in terms of
you know approaching it but but at the
end of the day what happens in PR
practice is that our licensed
professionals review these materials and
if they don't feel that the the in in
the in the case that you gave that the
uh that the samples that have been taken
are representative of the of the
of the formation or that they are in
some way manipulated to try to force a
particular result they can call that out
and say they want more borings or they
want a broader you know uh array across
the site um so I don't I don't think I
can point to a place where it says
specifically that they have to be you
know spaced a certain distance or or um
cover an area in a particular way but
what really end up happening because
every site is different and every
circumstance is different is that our
professionals who are responsible for
reviewing will make a a professional
judgment call on whether those that
information and the location the samples
and the nature and the number of the
samples are adequate to answer the
question and if they're not we'll ask
for more and you know we it's um very
uncommon for a application for um a new
landfill site or a um what's more common
for us is an expansion of existing
landfill for that application to be
deemed complete on first try it almost
never happens there's always additional
almost always additional information
that we're looking for can can I ask a
follow up on that yeah yeah please thank
you very and and thank you and I
appreciate that uh and it makes sense
based on the the feedback you're getting
from the experts where I'm a little
confused still though is that given the
response that that you just gave
the term representative actually seems
more uh descriptive of what you just uh
referred to whereas average implies that
there is a numerical standard uh a
specific numerical standard and that a
judgment would be based not
on professional judgment about whether
or not it is representative it's based
upon a number and you either pass or you
don't pass based upon a number so again
I come back to uh a claim that I've made
previously that
representative uh is what we should be
aiming for here and as you said I think
it reflects more accurately the process
you just described than an average thank
you we'll we'll certainly note that and
I would encourage you or any others to
provide that in comment during the
public comment period certainly it's
something we can look at thank you thank
you Mr chair absolutely represent Penza
um okay so first I'd like to go to the
number 17 here um on the list in regards
with adding a requirement for testing of
lee8 so um so I would assume that would
be all of the leech that is either um if
it's being treated on a site in addition
to all the lri that's being trucked to
be treated elsewhere that's correct
every single every single truckload
every
single no I don't think it means that it
it means that we're going to want to
have representative sampling of lee8 so
that we can monitor lee8 quality it
doesn't mean that every truck load is
going to get tested I just want to be
clear about that there're several
truckloads per day that leave these
facilities and I don't think that's what
this rule was trying to accomplish so
give me a scenario of what it is trying
to accomplish then like I want to kind
of understand um if you're telling me
it's going to you know we're talking
about quarterly or I mean it the amount
of the amount of um of of pasas and all
all of these types of chemicals and a
whole bunch of other ones that is being
trucked out you know to different places
to be able to be treated is huge so I I
kind of want to understand like
frequency but then the second thing is
um we know that we know that you can't
really separate at this point there's
activated carbons that take away a
decent amount of past I've been kind of
studying this for a little bit now um
but in a sense you you really can't
remove it you really can't separate it
out from the leech eight so what's the
point of testing it if it goes to a
facility where we then separate out the
we're able to separate out but not get
rid of the pasas right and then it just
gets trucked back in and put back into a
landfill because that's actually what's
happening right now it's a it's a
vicious circle Yeah well yeah there's a
lot to unpack there so
um the purpose of this rule is to make
sure that we are getting data and there
are some frequencies for testing um
they're not but they're not intended to
evaluate the quality of Lee leaving the
site each day that's not the purpose of
our rule our rule is that we want to
have data where we understand the
quality of your lee8 over time so that
we understand you know and that can how
a Lee a changes not necessarily with
respect to pasas but its other
parameters can have uh can give us
insight and information to how the
landfill is operating it can give us
information about uh the the oxidation
or or or anoxic conditions in the
landfill it can give us information
about how the cover system and the liner
system are performing that's the purpose
for that and we're adding past
specifically because we know moving
forward that there are very likely to be
increased scrutiny on and and
limitations on what wastewater treatment
plants Municipal plants that accept
these materials um are going to be able
to do with it or what they're going to
be required to do with it so we don't
want to be flat-footed as that advances
we want to understand what lee8 looks
like at these facilities with respect to
pasas um what happens right now is that
you know these these landfills generate
tremendous amounts of Lee it has to be
said I think the total for one recent
year was around 12 million G gallons if
we look at all of our facilities in
aggregate um it's excuse
me I think it's around 100 million
gallons forgive me one of the facilities
was 12 million so it's a lot of lee8 and
it goes to a number of wastewater
treatment plants each facili is required
to have identified at least two
Wastewater plants that will accept their
leech a so they always have an outlet
for it because you can't stop it from
being generated right so um what happens
at those facilities right now um you're
right those those processes that are
used at a typical wastewater treatment
plant um do not treat past in any
meaningful way they essentially bated
some of it remains in the liquid portion
the treated effluent that gets
discharged to rivers in most cases um
and some of it goes into the partitions
into the sludge and ends up being in the
sludge um as we move forward there are a
number of facilities um TurnKey landfill
in Rochester is traing for pasas um at
least a significant portion of their
leech eight they have a pretty
sophisticated wastewater treatment plant
there where they treat um where they've
treated even before anybody was thinking
about past they were treating their
leech eight for other purposes because
in order to send it to the Rochester
Wastewater Plant it needed to meet
certain standards so um as part of that
um they do a rever a reverse osmosis
process that pretty effectively reduces
and removes P from their leech eight um
and there the question is what are you
going to do with that you know you get a
you get a concentrate from that what are
you going to do with that my
understanding is that for a long time
they were sending it to one of their New
York facilities that was doing further
treatment I'm not sure what they're
doing with it right now there's a lot of
um work going on right now with new
technologies um there's super critical
water oxidation there's reverse osmosis
there's granulate activated carbon and a
lot of work is going on as we speak to
evaluate how
landfill leech AIDS can be treated by
those methods and I think that if we
look to the Future what we're going to
have and we most probably people
probably know it was announced in early
April I think April 10th that EPA has
finalized its P drinking water maximum
contaminant limit particularly for pooa
and posos which are two of the compounds
that we deal with most in New Hampshire
to four parts per trillion and then um
that is eventually not quite yet because
it's a drinking water standard but
eventually that's going to translate to
um some limitations on Wastewater plants
so if you have a uh drinking water
intake on a river say the marac river um
where and we do have that we have you
know facilities penchuk and and uh and
uh and Manchester pull water from the
marac river um if you have a Wastewater
Plant that's within 20 mi Upstream of
that what drinking water intake you're
going to need to make sure that your
discharge meets that drinking water St
standard so that's going to mean right
now you know we see as you get into the
upper reaches of the miramac I think
we're seeing ambient concentrations of
pasas on the order of 2 to three to four
um and then as you get into the lower
portion of the marac in the southern
part of the state there are times when
it's above four it's still single digits
but it's above four so that's going to
be a concern I mean those and I I don't
want to cause Panic the uh the um the
folks who are pulling drink water are
are treating with carbon to make sure it
meets standards before they send it to
their customers but that's a long way of
saying there's going to be a lot going
on with respect to how we handle um all
Wastewater and it has to be said that um
while Landfield le8 has significant
concentrations of pasas the wastewaters
coming into Wastewater facilities have
lower concentrations but their volume is
much higher so it may seem a little
counterintuitive but what you'll find
like the waste the minaki river base in
Franklin which is the plant that the
state of New Hampshire operates um takes
um leech 8 from the Bethlehem landfill
and you know they did an analysis of
their flows and the the average
concentration of pasas in their incoming
flows and then that leech eight and the
volumes of that and the reality is is
that it doesn't really move the needle
at that particular plan because the the
relative concentration or the relative
mass coming in from the high volumes of
flow they're getting from their regular
customers kind of is what controls what
their eventual P effluent concentrations
are more so than the much smaller
volumes but higher concentration of P
coming in from Le okay that's and that's
awesome except for we're looking at
landfill mhm and so the sludge does that
go back into landfill or does that go
another place in many cases I opened up
Pandora's
Box app
that's that's fine so so yeah it depends
um there are um a number of facilities
that do landfill their wastewater
treatment sludge so there is you know
sort of that Circle that representative
paten is referring to where leech a
comes in they treat it some of it goes
out in the treated effluent to the river
some of it gets partitioned into the
sludge and in some cases that sludge may
be going back to landfill okay is that
is that I mean to me that doesn't make
sense is it possible to
write that into the rules
that that that I mean why would you
separate it out if you're just going to
put it back
in well
um I I think you could probably say that
about a lot of contaminants because the
sludge has a lot of things in it and um
the you know for better for worse um
obviously the leate needs to be treated
and the receiving stream at the
Wastewater Plant needs the quality of
that stream needs to be protected so
they're going to do whatever treatment
they can um and then make sure that
their treated effluent meets all the
standards for discharge to the river and
then you have to do something with the
sludge and uh the safest and most
effective way to manage that sludge at
present is to put it back in the
landfill okay understand
um uh represent Murray then represent
Penza uh thank you um so one of the
things that I was looking at and and I
think you know that I've been uh looking
into some of the changes you made I
think in 8067 L and 80706 and I thought
I was confusing the same thing at once
but one is post closure and one is
somewhere else um and it was around
incident reporting mhm and so I went
back and took a very good look at
incident reporting and I understand
that's a different rules section and we
could slice this a couple of different
ways um the current you know the current
suggestion that you all have is to
revert or to refer back to the 17 uh
1000 section
10509 um but previously you had given
sort of metrics for date and time of
notifying like the length of time I
think it was said within one week of the
discovery of an issue um so my question
to you is uh when I looked at the 1000
section um the language in the 1000
section sort of is kind of squishy it's
open it says as soon is um I believe it
says I'm looking here per becomes aware
yeah and so um it's kind of that
open-ended sort
of situation we find ourselves in so
what does that mean does that mean
within 24 hours 48 hours you know I or
is that immed like immediately someone
picks up the phone because it's verbally
for the most part here and then there's
not much in writing so I just was
curious about that so yeah we've talked
about this I think our last time so
thank you for thank you for keeping it
on the Forefront
um immediately means different things to
different people right um we take in um
information and incidents uh verbally
sort of enough to to understand how long
it should take um but that shouldn't be
a guessing game for the Pere so like
like we mentioned last time our goal is
to open that setback up very soon and
Des squishy that rule right so it's it's
not it isn't helpful to have something
that you're kind of bandying back and
forth on well did that is that really
immediately or not so we're going to
work we're going to work to chip away at
that rule to make it much clearer for
the per and and us us as well so in and
may I follow up please so in the
drafting process as it exists now I'm
just trying to understand when
I think about registering my thoughts
with you all in that way um what is
suggested currently is um would you
point us to exactly to where you're
looking at so I'm sure we're yes thank
you this was again on that
um let me go back and look again on the
um I think the March 8th 24
document and give me two seconds
if and I'm looking at
80706 which says post closure
use okay so one of those it says um just
that uh e little bracket e if damage
occurs to any component of the landfill
closure system during the post closure
use the d uh the damage shall be
reported in a timely manner and the
incident reported to the department in
in accordance with uh
1059 so it's it's all over that sort of
section and then the one above and
8067 okay right so uh what how I how I
how I would read this as a perit is I
need to take care of the damage
immediately concurrently I need to
report it verbally and I need to follow
up with an incident report within five
working
days so it's not it's not a I have to I
have to fix it in a timely manner first
and then I get to wait a certain amount
of time to verbally report and um report
in writing do separate so you take care
of it at the same time you need to call
the department and you need to uh file
an incident report great okay well I'll
share my thoughts in further detail
thank you thanks good represent pz
okay okay so this is going to go back to
the past piece and and what triggered my
this question has a lot to do with
number 17 on here so as as you may or
may not know our entire committee here
as well as you know just our full
environment and agriculture committee
and I believe that the Senate has copied
on this too um we
receive letters that are from that are
going to Dees we've received letters
that are coming back from Dees so you
recently sent a letter um to the
attorney for the North Country Alliance
for balance change and I'm going to read
this stating that P and other
contamination on an offsite at Bethlehem
is not coming from an active landfill
leak but can be attributed to the
countless spills and accidents over the
years so my first question is is that
supposed to be
okay accidents and Spills we're just
thinking that that's okay it's not part
of the rule making yes it is because it
has everything to do it has everything
to do with Ru making because if
we're so I want to understand because if
we're if we're gonna we're gonna add in
a requirement here for testing of leech
eight and we're going to be looking at P
if we if we have folks now in an active
landfill status that are saying hello
there's a problem and we're just saying
oh well that's just from spills that's
just from accidents so I just don't
understand what are what are we doing
we're not investigating it um you know
is there a liner leak at NCS why why
aren't we looking at that like I just I
don't understand that we're we're we're
building all of these rules right to
have these safeguards in place when we
have stuff going on right now so why
aren't we looking at stuffs that's going
on right
now there there are no circumstances
where we become aware that there's been
an accident or a spill or a release
where we don't require followup or we
don't make the applicant investigate
that and address the release so that it
doesn't create a groundwater problem
that these rules in fact lay out the
provisions for that and so
um that is that's not intended in any
way to suggest that that's okay it's
never okay when there's a spill or
release of leech eight and when it occur
but it does occur and it occurs at all
of our
facilities at one time or another and
when that happens there's a very
specific process for invest ating the
nature of that um and and getting to the
bottom of it making sure that it doesn't
happen again and remediating any of the
release that's
occurred isn't there fines that are
involved in that too there can be
absolutely so the spill that took place
at NCS ncees or whatever in
2021 there haveen from what I've looked
at there's been no fines imposed and all
of that that's one of the largest leate
spills that we've had in the state I
think by far from my investigation we
don't discuss our enforcement matters
that with
with we we just don't discuss those
that's I'm fine whatever any further
questions all
right no I almost
yes please thank you Mr chair uh so I
did want to ask it was an email I sent
out actually on Sunday uh to uh uh
direct whims I think actually
uh I think Sarah uas krent I put on
there instead of my apologies uh and
also uh you guys on on Sunday and the
question was about um and this goes
to how we can tell our constituents that
this is a process that is driven
by public health and the need to protect
the environment more than it's driven by
economic interests right and then so my
question
was whether
the rules that the first draft of rules
in October right if we were still
looking at those rules if the proposed
landfill in Dalton would have been able
to meet some in particular the uh
Hydro
[Music]
um why is the terms escaping me
hydraulic cond thank you thank you
hydraulic conductivity uh me standard in
that because that's one of the things
that has been decreased over the course
of the rules because I think it's going
to be really hard for us to convince the
public especially people in the North
Country That That economic interests
aren't driving this if you know that GS
cell permit would not have qualified
under the October rules but would now
qualify under current rules as they've
been revised especially since as you've
pointed out right you those changes have
been made in large part because you said
you listened to the regulated industry
one of whom uh is the company who uh has
that permit so this this is
unfortunately a product of the fact that
you're in the very unenviable situation
of being
of looking at a permit application at
the same time that you're making rules
and the public has to know that those
two things are not related to each other
and the best way that I can think of is
to ask the question given the permit
that is in front of you would that
permit have passed under the the
stricter rules that were in place in
October um and would they uh would they
meet especially the hydraulic
conductivity standard that is in the
rules as we see them now yeah I I don't
know the answer to that we heard from a
broad spectrum of landfill operators and
owners across the state who all
uniformly Express concerns about that
provision and and the um Express
concerns that existing facilities or new
facilities could not be um could not be
permitted under that provision and so we
um we looked at that and and we made the
decisions we made about where we thought
the proposed rule ought to be um I don't
we we don't have yet a complete
application for the facility that you
referenced um and I don't honestly know
you know until we reviewed that and
looked at all the data once it's
complete um I don't know whe whether it
would have met that prior draft proposed
rule from October or not okay thank
you all
right thank you so much for your time
this is a a lot of a lot of hard work
thank you for that very helpful for us
um still some questions out there but
moving
forward right thank you yeah thank you
and is there a representative from Mike
morale office here no I don't
think
okay um we'll have to fire the chair
must Miss yeah I don't know he just sent
me a note this morning okay thank you so
much I appreciate you
coming oh I just sent him a note said
we're in 307 and it says 307 downstairs
so yeah it's on the board if he looks
yeah
e
e for